[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno hoy voy a contar una historia pero
todo que pediros disculpas porque antes
necesito decir hacer una encuesta aquí
entre todos
y también los de atrás no os vais a
librar
y os voy a ponerlo lo primero de todo os
voy a pedir que os pongáis de pie y lo
siento mucho pero tenéis que hacer más
muy rápido porque no habrá mucho tiempo
todos de pie los de atrás también
vale ahora escondido que era broma no
vale ahora voy a pedir que os sentéis a
una serie de personas se voy a pedir que
otras os quedéis de pie vale por favor
no hagáis trampas sobre todo intentar
pensar y ser ser sinceros vale voy a
pedir que os sentéis antes de hacerlo yo
os daré la orden de ya vale os voy a ver
con sentáis las personas que no vivís
que no vivís en zonas rurales y voy a
pedir que os quedéis de pie los que
vivís en pueblos o zonas rurales
esto es para simplificar vale por favor
a ver
los de las zonas rurales allí en pie
orgulloso sobre todo que se estará
mirando con mucha envidia a ver por aquí
detrás
bueno
no está no está nada mal
bueno nos hacemos una fotografía muy
interesante para poder sentarnos todos
por favor
bien
siento deciros que arabia pedir cosas
grandes por su vez pero no os preocupéis
nos tenéis que levantar todos vale para
la segunda pregunta y última pregunta
vale está ojo que la voy a matizar para
que no haya género de dudas os voy a
pedir que os levantéis
los que tenéis pueblo no levantes
todavía
voy a matizar
los que tenéis pueblo básicamente me
refiero no sólo a los que vivís y tenéis
pueblo me refiero también a los que
vuestros padres abuelos antepasados pues
tenía un pueblo tenéis un sitio dónde
vais en verano donde tenéis una casa
etcétera etcétera es de los que yo creo
que me entendéis no los que tenéis
pueblo venga arriba
igual
muy bien muchas gracias yo te puedes
sentar ya hemos hecho la encuesta
bueno pues yo yo también yo también
tengo pueblo
y os lo presentó
se llama prior
y frías
y bueno prioro para los que no lo
conocéis es un pequeño pueblo en la
montaña oriental leonesa en un valle
rodeado de paisajes alucinantes de
montañas de bosques de hayas de robles
un sitio muy muy bonito
pero yo no nací allí ni me creía allí
yo soy de ciudad y nací en barcelona
y yo soy hijo de inmigrantes que un día
decidieron dejar sus pueblos para ir a
la ciudad hace ya muchos años y qué pasa
que cuando vives en la ciudad pues para
ti el sitio normal
el sitio estándar de vida es la ciudad
difícilmente te planteas otra cosa
pero yo tenía un secreto yo tenía pueblo
y mis padres todos los veranos me
llevaban de la ciudad al pueblo y claro
imaginaros desde pequeñito pues aquello
era indescriptible pasaba del asfalto a
estar acompañando a mi abuelo a ordeñar
las vacas con mis primos a por hierba
con el tractor además que será
alucinante
y por ejemplo podrías encontrarte un día
llevando un rebaño de vacas
claro todas esas experiencias las
experiencias me cambiaron la vida me
cambiaron completamente la vida me
hicieron ver el mundo de otra manera el
caso es que hace unos días cuando cuando
estaba preparando esta charla decidiera
internet pero como el pueblo tenemos
mucho tiempo libre decía internet a
mirar datos
yo voy a mirar datos a ver cómo están
las zonas rurales ahora mismo en españa
y en el mundo yo lo voy a pasar muy
rápido porque los datos suelen ser muy
aburridos pero yo lo sé recopilado en
tres diapositivas muy rápidas la primera
es la población rural en el mundo esta
gráfica muestra la población rural en el
mundo y son datos del banco mundial y
como podemos ver pues bueno la línea
baja básicamente es decir el futuro
según los datos está en las ciudades y
en las mega ciudades todo el mundo está
yendo en masa a vivir a las ciudades
en el 2007 pasamos el 50 por ciento de
cierre en 2007 más personas vivían ya en
ciudades que en zonas rurales pero es
que aquí en españa la situación es mucho
más curiosa
la población rural en españa a día de
hoy es del 20% que vive en un territorio
que es más grande que algunos países
europeos
es un territorio que está vacío
prácticamente demográficamente
como podéis ver ahí en 1980 pues la cosa
se enfrenó porque fue hecha gran
inmigración la que ocurrió por ejemplo a
mis padres pero desde entonces la línea
no ha parado de descender
y un último dato
cuatro mil cuatro mil son los pueblos
que están en riesgo de desaparición 4000
municipios
que tienen menos de 500 habitantes y que
están en riesgo de desaparecer y muchos
de ellos van a desaparecer
inevitablemente
qué ocurre que esos 4.000 municipios son
la mitad de los municipios que hay en
españa
y esos son muchos lugares
y claro cuando ve uno esto y quiere dar
una charla optimista sobre el pueblo
pues se te pone la guasa complicada así
que dije bueno yo lo voy a intentar
volvemos a prior
bueno el caso es que mucha gente se
preguntará bueno y por qué me importa a
mí todo esto pues porque desde hace ya
varios años
ya no vivo en la ciudad vivo en el
pueblo vivo en mi pueblo vivo en prior
y claro
no solo me importa a mí me importa
también lógicamente por toda la gente
que vive en el pueblo mis amigos mi
familia mis vecinos un montón de gente
que vive allí y que quieren seguir
viviendo allí pero ven como sus pueblos
se van fundiendo a negro poco a poco
el caso es que en
intenté desde el principio dar la charla
optimista y dije bueno lo voy a intentar
sobre todo porque hay que romper muchos
mitos
muchos mitos sobre los pueblos
los pueblos hoy en día ya no son lo que
yo vivía cuando iba con a visitar a mis
abuelos desde pequeñito los pueblos hoy
en día están en un mundo conectado y
globalizado como las ciudades
exactamente igual
y claro eso es para lo bueno y para lo
malo pero yo voy a contar cinco cosas
buenas muy rápidamente
la primera de ellas es que
la contaminación por ejemplo los pueblos
es prácticamente
inexistente en comparación con las
ciudades la contaminación lumínica y
lumínica la contaminación acústica
la contaminación ambiental por ejemplo
poder escuchar el sonido del silencio o
la naturaleza o poder ver las estrellas
por ejemplo por la noche eso es
maravilloso sobre todo para un fotógrafo
como yo
luego también está el sentimiento de
comunidad dentro de los pueblos es
maravilloso y nada tiene que ver con las
ciudades os invito a explorarlo el hecho
de que una sola persona vaya a vivir a
un pueblo es tan importante como si van
mil o diez mil a una ciudad cada persona
en el pueblo es muy importante
luego la calidad de vida la vida
sencilla en los pueblos se vive mejor
con menos
y eso es lo que yo he podido comprobar
desde que estoy allí
porque porque te quitas lo
imprescindible o sal perdón lo
prescindible de la vida lo acabas
quitando porque en el line 2 ingresa de
un pueblo es así
y luego está también otro tema la que
relación con la naturaleza estamos
dejando de conocer la naturaleza porque
vivimos en ciudades
y el conocimiento de la naturaleza es
muy importante que lo conservemos porque
si no nos puede pasar cosas como esta
noticia que vi hace dos semanas en
internet
16 millones de norteamericanos creen que
la leche con chocolate proviene vacas
marrones
claro que podéis decir bueno está allí
pues no
eso es porque allí hacen esas
estadísticas pero si la escena aquí
imaginaros yo que sé que el queso azul
como es azul pues proviene de vacas
azules yo que sé
muchos ojos
porque esto es broma pero por si acaso
este fin de semana hacer una visita al
campo vale no os pido orden y es una
vaca pero bueno le podéis hacer una foto
si queréis
bien
bueno y por último internet internet ha
cambiado
la vida en los pueblos la equiparado
prácticamente a las ciudades
y por ejemplo pasar hoy en día la
comunicación el acceso a la información
el acceso a las compras podemos comprar
lo que queramos nosotras en la casa
el acceso a la cultura poder estudiar
una carrera a través de internet conozco
mucha gente que lo hace
o una cosa muy importante para mí que es
trabajar porque yo trabajo a través de
internet y eso me permitió ir a vivir y
quedarme y viviendo en prioro
esta es una fotografía de mi abuelo
mi abuelo benito
y esa es la época más o menos en la que
yo iba de pequeño a visitarle
en esa ventana que veis a mano derecha
con esa ventana estaba la cocina la
trébede y mi abuelo durante los veranos
me enseñaba a leer ahí
ojalá ojalá
el estuviese aquí para ver que 30 años
después yo estaría en esa misma casa
detrás de esa misma ventana una casa ya
nueva diferente pero el mismo lugar con
mi oficina montada trabajando a través
de internet con clientes internacionales
cuando estoy de viaje o cuando no estoy
en un rodaje estoy ahí en esa misma casa
en el mismo lugar en el mismo pueblo y
entonces pensé es posible si yo estoy
allí otra persona puede encontrar su
método para el ver a un pueblo si quiere
vivir en un pueblo y en un pueblo se
vive muy bien
porque lo que más plantea y es el futuro
de los pueblos
tenemos que pensar como queremos que
sean los pueblos nuestros pueblos en el
siglo 21
porque si no un día
os presento a mi sobrino héctor
que ya ha visitado dos veces el pueblo y
tiene un año y medio
y si un día el mi sobrino vector así de
pequeño crece y dentro de 30 ó 40 años
estuviese aquí mismo
dándonos una charla a todos nosotros y
nos preguntarse quién tiene pueblo que
es elegante a lo mejor no se levanta
nadie
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]